Rogers alert president Trump campaigning
in key Senate battleground states he's
finishing up a rally right now in West
Virginia before heading to Indiana later
tonight just minutes ago the president
going after Democrats hard ahead of the
high stakes midterms just four days away
the Democrats want to raise your taxes
restore job-killing regulations shut
down your coal mines and by the way they
will shut down your coments you know
that they want to take away your good
health care and essentially use
socialism to turn America into Venezuela
Trump also touting the booming economy
after finding out today 250,000 jobs
were added in October America now has
the best economy in the history of our
country and we want to keep it that way
we've created 4.5 million new jobs since
the election a number that was
unthinkable if I would have said that
during the campaign oh they would have
given me a hard time say what I said
Pinocchio you know they do the whole
thing the president also hitting on a
central theme of his midterm campaign
the migrant caravan that's headed
towards the United States
Democrats want to totally open the
borders they have the caravan Letterman
do you want to let them in does anybody
want
caravan after caravan is forming
unvetted illegal aliens trying to flood
into our country on your dollar
overwhelming your school's depleting
your resources and endangering your
community all right there we go there
was another former president former
president on the campaign trail today
let's play that from President Obama and
then we'll take it around the table well
you're distracted with all this stuff
they're making up there also robbing you
blind I'll be like look look over there
and then they're giving tax cuts to
billionaires look over there then
they're letting polluters poison your
air and water they will absolutely take
health care away from millions the first
chance they get while you are distracted
with stuff that is not true all right
Jesse let me hand over to you both
former President Obama and President
Trump kind of having fun on the campaign
trail yeah President Obama looked pretty
spry right there when he was bouncing
it's got a little pep in his step I do
think he's really lowered himself to a
place where he shouldn't be as a someone
that's just left office I don't think
there's ever been a president this early
to campaign so partisan Lee against his
successor in that way but you know what
he's trying to salvage his legacy
because Donald Trump has totally
destroyed it the president got some
great news today on the economy a
quarter million jobs created in October
despite the hurricane and when some
other bright spots three point one
percent wage growth that is the best
wage growth for American workers in a
decade also nearly 70,000 jobs created
in construction and mining and
manufacturing remember those jobs were
never coming back according to Barack
Obama Louis unemployment levels since
1969 most Americans with the job in
American history and the media has
really downplayed this economy when
there was the 3.5% GDP number that just
came out the other day the nightly
newscasts they never even covered it and
then too
Axios said well you know the economy is
shrinking it went from four point two to
three point five just and they say you
know in a recession maybe around the
corner I do think the president is
closing strong on the message of the
economy and on immigration and this blue
wave that everybody says is gonna happen
I'm not quite so sure about it right now
maybe just like a little ripple maybe
I'm Greg the other economic number was
the lowest unemployment rate for
veterans it's great that they've had a
long economy is hotter than Jessie and
cut offs but it's yes I did I have a
camera in your dressing room okay here's
the deal
like you know what the the the media
isn't covering this news because it's
not something that you can blame on
Trump it's something you have to give
credit for so they'd rather just you
know do their usual anti-trump blather
which also happens to gin up their
revenues quite well as Jeff Zucker has
admitted recently either way the way I
look at the midterms and I pray that
they're over soon the Republicans win
and the Democrats lose no matter what no
matter what and I'll tell you why
because politics isn't personal to
Republicans so if you do well great but
I'm gonna go have dinner but if you lose
the house well that sucks
but I'm gonna go have dinner but now the
Democrats let's say the Democrats win
big that's not going to be enough
because he's still going to be in charge
that evil Trump is still gonna be there
so they're still gonna be really angry
and if they lose we saw what happened
when they lost before right it was a
countrywide tantrum yes the scream so
the thing is because it's so intensely
personal for Democrats primarily
liberals with politics I don't think
they're ever gonna be pleased by the
outcome where the Republicans politics
is just a facet in your life it's one
part of it it's not your life so you
know you lose the house you know well
that's life I'm gonna go play with my
kids how do you think I can have kids or
whatever you want to say oh well I just
AM amazed it's the best economy ever
since Trump and Jesse backed it up of
course just not true and then you say
it's not true and people are like well
why are you picking on the present no
stop picking utter than the
but I'm insist unbelievable and then you
know the whole idea that this invading
army is coming oh my gosh do you want to
let them in you know it's just
ridiculous but you know to me it's at
the point where in this campaign you
look at where the president's going you
look at what he's saying so today West
Virginia also Indiana
he's going into red states and he's
trying his best I don't think he's gonna
have any success with stopping Joe
Manchin getting reelected but when it
comes to Joe Donnelly the Democrat in a
red state like Indiana I think he may
have some success because he can stir up
the base and that's all he's doing so
the whole attack on the on the caravan
everything that he says about the the
caravan being filled with disease and
criminal you know it's just some point
you want to think are these Republicans
paying attendance it make any different
to say we were poisoning though didn't
just say we're poisoning the air in
water your thoughts about we have a week
we're going into a weekend it is also
when you have to turn back the clocks by
the way yeah what's a clock apparently I
think that that is probably good news
for Republicans right and I'm kidding I
don't in the past
listen I think it all comes down to
under sided voters which are largely
independents largely moderates and
something that I thought was interesting
and in this before the the mail bomber
happened before the temple shooting
happened
most of those independent voters are
registering saying that they felt unsure
about putting the Democrats back in
power because the message did work that
they thought theirs too they were too
extreme clearly the events you know sort
of stopped the momentum that they had
but they still sort of seemed like we'll
I vote will I not vote what will happen
and we all know in all of these
elections it depends on who can motivate
people to to turnout so what I'm
fascinated by I started going through
you know state-by-state we're all
looking at the polling I think it's
gonna be a really long election I'm
looking forward to watching you Dana
because those the want will be there too
and one too I won't you can come to my
party
oh great that's the as the wind blows
these races like they're a plane apart
right are there two points apart within
the margin of error we can see the
Senate look looking exactly
we can see the house looking similarly
or we could see you know we could see
something go straight up or down for
either party mean it's going to be a
fascinating evening and then one thing
that I would say is to pay attention not
just to the house and to the Senate but
these governor's races 12 out of 13
Republican governors that are running
for re-election are ahead but seven
about seven and nine of them that are
running in open seats it's it's
neck-and-neck talk about Georgia talk
about Florida I mean these are the races
where it could go into runoff so we
could be up all night I just want to
pick up on something that Morgan just
said she's right there's a lot of House
races right now that a lot of
prognosticators think oh you know what
Democrats are going to get them all
they're all within the margin of error
so there's no guarantee that this blue
wave is going to happen you can see a
situation where Democrats pick up 20
seats in the house and come up a few
seats short there's no massive
democratic party registration going on
there's no massive enthusiasm gap going
on there's no recession going on there's
just not a lot of indicators look at the
generic congressional ballot that's
within single digits the Democrats are
down in the Connecticut governor's race
some good reason I mean there's just a
lot of things that you scratch your head
and you think wait a second the media
was so wrong in 2016 could this be a
flashback of what happened last time
there could be a silent majority out
there that aren't talking to pollsters
it could come out and then really
shocked the crowd I think you go looking
and look at the ads just so important
right now and the ads both on the
Republican and we gotta love her charts
it's a great chart and I send it to
everyone this morning so that they could
take it 7:00 in the morning you get like
eight charts from Dana oh great just
what I want to look at when I wake up in
the morning
stuff like this what just send me
pictures of your dog instead well that
can be arranged it tells you what ads
were running in which regions of the
country so I thought
charts before 9 a.m.
somebody has to get up early to work on
the two o'clock Dana I must say I valued
it and but I just wanted to my point
that I was going to make based on Dana's
chart by the way would be that health
care dominates on both sides not this
immigration drivel and not the phony ad
that makes it out like Democrats want
open borders again it's like our
Republican suckers what is going on why
show that chart one more time at the
chart one more time what that is what it
would be a great oh they're not showing
we're gonna show the chart one more time
can we pull it back up no you know what
it's not even worth it forget it as you
say it's a great place mat for a diner
like where you are
exactly I'm telling you Bill Hemmer
would appreciate that chart